[Music]
[Music]
lumos
what do you think you're doing here
humans
welcome to hogwarts legacy
you're a new student at the famed school
of witchcraft and wizardry with a unique
ability to manipulate powerful ancient
magic hidden in the wizarding world
you'll need to uncover what's behind the
return of this forgotten magic and who
is seeking to harness it to destroy
wizard kind as you may be the one that
decides the fate of the entire wizarding
world
but before you can study magic and begin
to solve these mysteries you must create
the witch or wizard you want to be
when you arrive at hogwarts you will be
sorted into one of the four hogwarts
houses gryffindor hufflepuff ravenclaw
or slytherin after you settle into your
dormitory you will meet up with your
housemates in the common room you will
then need to attend classes and you do
have some catching up to do as you were
starting hogwarts late as a fifth year
so you are the new student
you'll begin your studies attending
charms defense against the dark arts
herbology and potions classes to name a
few
oh hello
class
please welcome the newest rose in our
garden
shall we begin
welcome to year five of chance now this
will be a crucial year in your education
on the art of charm work but i am
confident that we will take hold with a
passion and rigor requisite of such a
challenge
the best way to practice is by dueling
we'll start with youtube
time for a proper hogwarts welcome
you may begin
not bad for a
beginner oceans is one of the most
challenging and hazardous subjects
taught at this school here you'll meet
your professors and learn to cast spells
grow magical plants brew potions and
more in between classes you'll be able
to explore the castle famous for its
secrets
enchantments and mysteries
you'll discover dungeons and secret
passageways
[Music]
as well as challenging puzzles that will
require magical skill and a clever mind
to solve
you may even find yourself in iconic
locations you've never been able to
explore before
[Music]
it's the late 1800s so while the common
rooms and classes may be familiar most
of your professors will not be however
you may recognize a few faces
[Music]
once patrick lets me join the headless
hunt i'll be right there with them this
offering is sure to win them over oh
don't forget why i'm here sir
you'll come to know this eclectic group
of talented witches and wizards in class
and while completing side assignments
that are part of a special curriculum
ones designed to help you catch up with
the other fifth years at your own speed
[Music]
opportunities for adventure abound in
the area surrounding hogwarts
the magical abilities you learn to
master through your schoolwork will soon
become tested as you unravel a dangerous
mystery by working alongside the
accomplished and yet enigmatic professor
fig to try and discover if the rumors of
a mounting goblin rebellion hold any
weight and if the safety of hogwarts
lies in the balance i have
opinions differ as to how great a threat
he really is
[Music]
loyalists are capable of so much more
than people realize the wizarding world
of this era is fraught with dangers
creatures corrupted by a magical force
powerful goblins
and sinister witches and wizards all
willing to fight even kill to achieve
their own goals
in fact there's an uneasy alliance
between the goblins and dark wizards
you said you could get to the child when
they came to hogsmeade that all you
needed was a distraction i gave you a
distraction i just watched a student
take down your distraction
who is this child you're not telling me
but perhaps you shouldn't involve
yourself with that just yet
[Music]
enemies possess unique defensive and
offensive abilities including blasting
curses stunning spells enchanted
weaponry and more while some may attack
directly others might enchant and
incapacitate you
mastery of the shield charm allows you
to deflect ranged spells and direct
weapon strikes
counter-attack with powerful stunning
charms allowing you to follow up with
extended spell combinations
[Music]
students who become particularly adept
at spell casting will find many ways to
exploit their enemy's weakness
[Music]
[Music]
slam with descendo
roast with incendio
devastate your enemies using various
finishes
you can even use the mysterious powerful
magic your professors do not understand
to obliterate your strongest foes
mixing and matching dozens of spells
will let you define your combat style
on your path to become the ultimate
dualistic
[Music]
perhaps you'd be good enough to blast
each other to pieces on your own time
in addition to classes and spells you'll
have access to a deep set of upgrades
talents and skills to aid your
progression as a wizard
complete challenges throughout the world
to earn experience level up your
abilities by choosing talents to upgrade
your spells plants and potions to
increase their power decide which
talents best fit your playstyle to allow
you to focus on your favorite types of
magic
you can also loot buy or craft your own
magical gear
that will increase your offensive and
defensive capabilities in combat
gear can be upgraded and specialized to
allow for greater abilities for your
chosen play style use a strong even
motion when crossing your ingredients
[Music]
spells are not the only tools at your
disposal in combat as you hone your one
skills you can continue to further your
magical education at hogwarts
progressing your development as a witch
or wizard
brew potions that can increase your
power when you need a boost
[Music]
grow and deploy magical plants to mob
the battlefield and keep your enemies at
bay
[Music]
you can even unleash deadly mandrake
seedlings to incapacitate unsuspecting
enemies
in beast's class you will learn about a
variety of magical beasts you might
encounter both at school and as you
explore the world surrounding the castle
and its grounds the goal of today is to
remind all of you how to maneuver on a
broomstick safely
learning and mastering broom flight is
highly recommended so that you may
travel around the world more quickly
i want you to do my herbology homework
you're despicable
some abilities may be taught to you by
students who become your friends
[Music]
as you develop relationships with these
schoolmates they can accompany you on
your journey as your companions
[Music]
and over time you'll learn their stories
this is our chance
natsai onai is a brave adventurer driven
by the justice she seeks
poppy sweeting has a kind heart and
loves magical beasts connecting with
them more easily than with humans but
what happens now unafraid of detention
or breaking the rules
section again is sebastian sallow a
charismatic slytherin we've been over
this boy triple figs cannot reverse a
curse with a troubling family secret
nothing can the sooner you accept that
reality the better you'll meet these
students and more as you explore common
rooms hallways between classes and
regular gathering areas
welcome to the room of requirement
[Music]
one of the most remarkable secrets of
hogwarts is known as the room of
requirement
you're introduced to this space that
seems to sense what you need and then
provides it for you
[Music]
since you need to catch up to your peers
the room provides space for you to sew
and harvest plants brew potions and
upgrade your gear
[Music]
a helpful house elf named deke helps you
discover the variants that allow you to
nurture your own menagerie of magical
beasts what is it
greek isn't sure
only one way to find out you can freely
customize this space to reflect your
personality and magical specialties
[Music]
not everything you need on your journey
is available at hogwarts you'll want to
visit the nearby wizarding village of
hogsmeade where loads of shops and
vendors can provide you with the
supplies you require
[Music]
from potion ingredients and recipes
to seeds for magical plants to all sorts
of gear
[Music]
but hogsmeade also has its dangerous
side a band of dark witches and wizards
emboldened by the turmoil of the times
wander the village outskirts
you must avoid them or defeat them
as you explore you'll find the world
surrounding hogwarts is alive with
activity wonders and areas of unusual
interest
as the school year progresses dynamic
seasons and climates will fill the sky
with lightning or sunshine or coach the
ground with snow or rain
unique wizarding hamlets pepper the
countryside
each with vendors and residents who have
stories to tell
and missions with which they could use
your assistance
be on the lookout for enchanting magical
puzzles that may very well have been
designed by merlin himself
when he was a student at hogwarts
magical beasts roam the lands outside
the castle walls some have been
corrupted by mysterious dark magic while
others are at risk of poachers and their
traps if you're feeling benevolent you
can rescue them and restore them to
health in the room of requirement
but there are dangers beyond your
understanding in the world as well
dungeons and vaults hold perilous
threats and also untold rewards
be careful where you choose to explore
as it may lead you down a darker path
master spells
befriend new allies journey across a
landscape never seen before uncover
ancient secrets combat mystical threats
learn long forgotten mysteries become
the witch or wizard you want to be
as you leave your unique mark on the
wizarding world
here
in hogwarts legacy
playstation